[موسيقى]
من الذي خط العلم
حقيقه
في البدايات الاولى كان الخط خط مما يبدو
لي يعني بسيط مثل هذا العلم جدا جدا ولكن
انا من خلال بحثي
وحاولت اسال واتوصل لمن قام بخط العلم
وجدت انه من البدايات الاولى
السيد عمر عاصم الحسني من اهل الجموم في
وادي فاطمه في مكه ممن ارتحل من مكه الى
الكويت وحينما زار الملك عبد العزيز
الكويت في 1910 ميلادي كان هو موجود في
الكويت وعين مديرا للمدرسه المباركيه
جدا وخط العلم الكويتي اللي كان باللون
الاحمر وكان يحمل كلمه كويت وهو من اوائل
من خط العلم السعودي بشكله الكوفي
[موسيقى]
في مرحله متقدمه حينما امر الملك عبد
العزيز طيب الله ترى بافتتاح دار القسوه
في مكه في عام 1926 عين عبد الرحيم امين
بخاري وهو من يقوم بكتابه
كل الايات القرانيه في كسوه الكعبه من ذلك
الوقت
فكلف بكتابه الاعلام السعوديه وتطريزها
[موسيقى]